hmm okay can you guys hear me oh man
yeah fan for sick Pam for stick sucks
it's awful like it's really bad it's so
bad it makes you wonder whether or not
Fox is really a viable company anymore
but uh yeah so anyway what's going on
guys just uh should be coming and good
you got your able to hear me phone and
she'll be able to see me fun stream
shouldn't be lying or anything if it is
let me know but did you drink your
bathwater that's kind of messed up let
me lower this down a little bit there we
go looks like it's a little high what's
up not everybody doing this woman how's
everybody doing today this beautiful day
I made the tales of five Fantastic Four
look like a masterpiece even though it
wasn't he had did yeah it made 75 now
fantastic four maybe look amazing which
kind of sucks because I maybe was bad
yeah at a pretty decent week trying to
get this thing perfectly set up
please let me know if you have November
DC or marvel book so you're looking
forward to in DC or January I'd like
metal man Metamorpho also earth one
Aquaman and flash yeah we'll see what's
up I mean right now I'm just kind of a
can't watch the stream on my phone that
sucks oh I think Aquaman will be the
next Galactus and all the way you
wouldn't be how's the gym going it's
going on fine picture to my left over
there that we talked about if you talk
about that one that's John Lennon it's
got the words to imagine written on it
kreygasm are straight are you hispanic
no I'm not it's funny question though
what do you think sick of war is ending
would be the end of the multiverse see
personally like I said I think that I
think the doctor doom made everything
like I think everything that has his
existing element in battle world was
made by dr. doom and I think that when
he dies because I think he's gonna die
and then that one day what he dies that
that's going to be the end of it it'll
be the end of out of world everything I
don't know dr. Doom's to become a
character to just kill though I couldn't
they can't just kill him be weird if
they did
where's my favorite comic out right now
mmm probably sick of worse white after
that though it was Green Lantern like
Green Lantern is really really good
right now like I'm really enjoying it
Rob I know you said you're from Kentucky
have you ever been to Derby City Comicon
no I haven't actually I didn't know that
existed what is it I'll be down to go to
I mean I love going to Comic Cons what's
the thing you're blowing into this is my
e-cigarette I'm trying to prime the tank
in here so I don't burn it out wise
doctor doing such a baller right now
because doom always has and always will
be pulling the strings it will always be
doom that pulls the strings you are so
great well thank you I appreciate it oh
man um what I would make a video about
blue Marvel I mean he's dead I don't
really see a reason to but I mean I'm
working on a video right now that we're
just like if you want to get into DC
Comics like would it start that those
are you guys just have my periscope the
other day that's what I'm making a video
on what's your favorite babe juice the X
is the one I'm using right now have you
Bethany why she comics now I haven't
with a ship they're really popular like
oh it's your number one so one like a
hundred thousand copies it's frickin
nuts I guess crazy how popular it is um
let's see have I ever read you a lot
multiverse no that'd be a cool game or a
cool a cool story to read I think them
like the multiple you what dragon ball
multiverse SL school um let's see how do
you how do you like tacos Mexican tuck
with this I mean oh hey do you like
mixed oh yeah I'm not talker stalkers
are amazing um follow mutants yep it's a
story it exists let's see what to do meu
to get so much power he saw the power
the beyonders we covered that in one of
our other videos let's see
deadpool is yeah deadpool desert awesome
are you going to go to New York Comic
Con yes i will be at new york comic con
with vinny and sound I Kember pfaff said
he could make it or not I don't I don't
know off top my head I think he said he
couldn't but I'll remember um can you
please say hi to Adrienne in Miami hello
Adrian in Miami how are you doing do you
like ee w eaten and that right now I
used to but not a big fan of it like I
was talking to a friend of mine and he
was like you know the Brock Mike brock
lesner and the inter ticker wrestling
and it was like means whatever i'm kind
of career she won between Brock Lesnar
and Undertaker I assume brock lesner one
so am i excited for civil war yeah who
wouldn't be who's not excited for civil
war that's my question that's what I
want to know like who would not be
excited for civil war like why would you
not be excited for that predictions for
SummerSlam I don't know um let's see
what happened to the comments on the
screen I don't know oh I forgot to have
those in actually i'll do that another
time like I put you forgot about the
head um let's see did you like Earth one
teen titans I haven't read that yet good
morning good morning can I say hi to you
uh hello la bossman Eli boss man what's
up broccoli I figured rockland 00 buck
listener oh it hasn't happened yet I
thought something was just weekend um
let's see what's in your hand skin this
is my e-cigarette someone in a coma I
don't think so you are so awesome thank
you so you're black I'm actually mixed
I'm black and white let's see what are
you gaping everybody's asking questions
about vaping i'm vaping the exes what
civil war Civil War is basically marbles
big crossover event pitting the
superheroes against each other over the
idea of superhuman Registration do you
ever eat Jimmy changos yes you just
joined this Q&A awesome have I been
keeping up with scoops
that heroic Hollywood has been dropping
out Civil War now I don't know they were
topping anything about it you're all
trying to explain was way better than
the movie I don't know about that who
would win the president versus the one
above all don't take it too seriously I
don't know me the presence that appeared
in like 17 comics I saw wasn't one above
all so they're both godlike characters I
imagine they'd be equal in power do you
think Fox should do a new mutinous
project no Fox should not do anything
with Marvel characters they suck at all
of it like it's just bad they had to
know whether it was bad going out the
day they had to know that when they
released the Fantastic Four that it was
going to be like really bad I they had
to know like this movie is going to suck
but we're going to release it anyway
because [ __ ] it we don't have standards
let's just make it you know because
whatever like what does make anything
instant it out where's Benny well this
is the doesn't my Q&A time Ben he said
he's on his way to France but he's not
usually here for my q and A's I don't
know why I'd be here now do you think
Deadpool can kill the DC Universe no not
by a long shot mm-hmm how do you keep up
with all these comments the best I can
is weird world any good it's the only
secret wars tie in on am i reading um
weird world was never really for me I
never got into it but i guess i miss
your thing you might enjoy it I never
really care for it to be honest let's
see what comic see recommend that have
released recently okay um pretty much
anything from DC like Stars start of
Starfire's really good um real anterin
lost armies really good Green Lantern
Sinestro Batman like Jim Gordon Batman
is amazing Superman the Superman true
story arcs going on right now Justice
League dark side wars going on right now
let's see um unmarked I'd its secret
horse and whatever tions happen to
interest you so I don't know um no Ben
he's on a flight to France she's not
gonna be calling any time
is there any real difference between
these mutant Registration Act and the
act of tony is fighting for yeah there's
massive differences the superhuman
Registration Act basically meant that
super humans would have to operate as
shield agents like they have to reveal
their identities and operated shield
agents the mutant Registration Act was
designed so that the government have a
way to like isolate track down mutants
and like kill them off oh yeah i'm
looking forward to metal gear solid 5
i'm looking forward to the expand to not
the expansion the the taken King
expansion to what am I thinking um am
the taken King expansion to destiny I'm
looking forward to let's see um what are
the games oh um no man's sky is going to
be amazing i'm really looking forward to
that say hello to your Australian
viewers what's going on Australian
viewers how you guys doing who's your
favorite superhero or villain Doctor
Doom was definitely my favorite villain
terms of superheroes mm probably the
century I love his story the most i
canceled my marvel unlimited
subscription because I know how lucky I
found Marvel's content reads to be well
if you don't like you didn't like it and
along with that sometimes it's just not
for you what's the meaning of life I
don't know to be happy life's too short
to live by other people's standards like
that's important what are your videos on
metal gears okay I didn't get a chance
to read all that are you pro or anti
Cyclops I'm kind of doesn't really
matter to me to be honest I don't really
care about Cyclops oh he's a cool
character he's been around for a long
time but I mean I'm kind of neutral
about him do you think Scott Lang will
become giant man in Civil War yes well
maybe not in civil war but at some point
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe he will
become giant man no black ops 3 Rob no I
got burned out on college ID a long time
ago I don't care about black ops have
you played batman arkham knight i'll
come not yet if so did you like it yeah
it was good it was long but it was good
I mean it was decent enough I mean I
wouldn't say it's the best game on her
made but it's pretty good do I prefer
amazing or ultimate spider-man huh
ultimate spider-man I like Miles Morales
let's see have you seen Smallville if so
what are your thoughts I never watched
smallville when I was young well I've
seen bits and pieces of it but it was
not enough for me to get interested in
it so but it's a I never really saw like
Superman that compelling of a character
like I never saw him like oh my god I
have to give up on Superman like I know
important events that are taking place
that's because he's so big it was
impossible to avoid but you know like
I'm not that well I will say this let
Superman truth is probably the best
Superman story I've cared about a long
time will you do a Fantomex explain
probably not um what about Mad Max the
game I didn't know they made a game no
nobody today guys um have you heard a
spider cat spider dog or even spiderpig
yeah I've heard of those do you play pvp
destiny ah yeah but PvP destiny is
really easy like I did I did a trials a
couple weekends ago and and those guys
of trials are easy like they're not very
hard I was playing on ps4 so maybe
that's a difference but there another
child is a lot easier than people make
it out to be I don't understand what
people say is really difficult um will
you join the Freemasons what power does
dr. doom have has he had he's just
really strong and mystics mysticism
different things like that where is the
Fenix the Fenix was probably looking for
a host right now as far as we know i
mean the Phoenix force is just out there
so can you explain the Enigma force it's
a force that's an enigma and it
originates from the micro universe
Microverse I think no it's called the
Enigma force because no one knows where
it came from let's see what do you think
about the most wanted to about the most
won a TV show I don't know what that is
I don't really watch TV shows if it's
out on net or is that unlike hulu plus
or HBO Go I don't know what it is or
amazon prime for netflix Godfather
Godfather to Godfather Godfather to was
good but it wasn't Godfather good so
your hair is on point I appreciate it
what character do you think the
tell-tale game will be about NM see you
I don't know but I'm really looking
forward to tail tail came and they make
such good games um i would say that man
i would say that huh probably Iron Man
or probably bout the Avengers in general
I'm not really sure either way I'm
psyched about it stop typing stop typing
let us scroll up there we go and put
user and time out there we go we're
going to put you out and tie it we're
gonna put you in timeout we're going to
treat you like a three rolls and put you
in timeout let's see least favorite
baton Oh Marvel's most wanted okay okay
I said what you're saying what are your
what about a Franklin Richards Phoenix
force to how ridiculously overpowered
would that be Franklin Richards with the
Phoenix force he would literally just
remake reality it would just be like
doom BAM you're bound you're out of here
by and that would be it so um are you
ready for Cena to come out of SummerSlam
16-time world champion no I'm ready for
potato salad to go away like I'm not a
big fan of potato salad he needs to I
mean it's I understand he's a big name
but it's time to go ahead and and you
know is I just time to go ahead and just
let that like that horse died so um
let's see do you like w.e SummerSlam is
today okay yeah SummerSlam is this
weekend okay okay for some reason I
thought it was last night ah Batman
Bruce Wayne or Jim Gordon I love Jim
reward I think Jim Gordon brings a real
light brings a uniqueness to to the
Batman series like I think he brings a
think you bring something that you just
wouldn't see under normal circumstances
so I think it's a really cool idea I
mean basically just seeing a person
struggle like that's something that you
never sell it Batman you never saw a
Batman struggle like you never saw Bruce
Wayne like oh my god I don't know what
to do here he's like BAM like I'm Batman
and I know everything because I'm the
smartest person on the planet I could
figure everything out and that's it so
why is dooms face so screwed up that's
well that's kind of the question is we
don't know if he screwed it up when he
had them when he put a burning-hot mask
on
his face or if it was screwed up
beforehand that question was never
answered so Who am I gonna vote for
president Deez Nuts Hillary Clinton or
Donald Trump well there's a lot of
popularity for these nuts so I don't
know but um are you watching the Gotham
TV series now I didn't get into it I'm
not a big fan of the Gotham TV series
best Marvel comic ever the five issue
limited series of the centuries origin
story definitely better let's see how
many Phoenix videos are you doing well
it's just that one video explaining the
Phoenix force it's just part of the
whole history of Jean Grey so what is an
external an external or an eternal
because there are different things are
you going to vote for president we
already asked that Oliver Queen versus
Bruce Wayne Bruce Wayne definitely let's
see hey Rob that people want to know
about moon night the people are you it's
just you because people like everybody
wants to know about moon night really or
just year so do you think old man Logan
will stay after singer Wars yes
definitely old man logo is not going
anywhere it's one of the best-selling
tie-ins for seeker worse it'd be
ridiculous as they get rid of it plus
it's one of the best stories they have
is to give or so here the question
here's a question I would ask brian
michael bendis is riding the tie-in so
if Secret Wars ends if he's not writing
it anymore will it be as good and if not
they're gonna get rid of it well been
destroyed a good iron man yeah he'll
write a really good iron man penis is a
really good writer he just doesn't
really pay attention to continuity DC
conversion storyline your thoughts it
was an excuse for DC to just bring back
hauls in reality so just say well we
don't have continuity anymore and we'll
cover that in my video about about
alternate realities it'll probably be a
seven or eight minute video it doesn't
need to be big there's no reason for two
but it'll be enough to basically make
things make sense for people can you
explain the anti-life equation we
explain that in my video about dark side
let's see who is your favorite favorite
x-men
ma'am no um probably imma frost Jesus
she's a solid character uh I see what
the hell is potato salad but if you
don't know the potato salad is and then
you're not keeping up with the current
trends you got to keep up my friend why
are you answered my question of course I
did it's a Q&A um rob is the bomb thank
you how is Batman dead in his own run
yet being a god and the darkside wars
well he's not dead in his own run but
that's the point of DC you dcu we should
just get rid of continuity and it's just
characters and stories and we'll answer
that question in my video about about DC
you and about what should what to do if
you want to get a DC Comics right now so
at the end of that video about you see
you that will answer your question so do
you like Alan Moore I like a lot more
stories i want to start reading x-men
where should I start uh I don't know why
you want to read it right now but um
yeah I mean if you want to read x men in
general I would say that start with all
new all different x-men and then read
some I mean you could read classic
stories like God loves man killed you
could read anything like the Phoenix
saga of the Dark Phoenix saga the House
of M decimation I mean there's all
different kinds of stuff out there let's
see who was a god and who is the god in
the DC Universe the presence we did a
video about him let's see the best food
ever mmm how we Chinese food or Italian
Italian is amazing let's see what you
ever dream up your own dream team of
heroes and villains for across all
comics probably I'd like to do that at
some point at some point in time where
as Deadpool during secret wars did he
die with the old universe no he's in
Deadpool secret secret wars so all they
did it was just basically like rewrite
the Secret Wars event and put Deadpool
in it so ah Grant Morrison's and on
Grant Morrison's new x-men yeah they're
pretty solid they're interesting um
should Nightwing get a TV show or a
movie I'd watch it I'd say a TV show I
think will be a cooler idea that I'm
but i'm watching either way it don't
matter to me what happens after infinity
war in the Marvel Cinematic Universe of
the comic let's see if Thanos
responsible for the universe not really
that's dr. doom face for wish list the
century at the Robert Reynolds I'd love
to see a story about him would you
rather since we got a TV show or a movie
a movie um let's see I don't have
twitter is the QA almost over now q when
I started 9 30 so we've been going for
about half an hour um let's see blade is
just dead yeah as far as I know blades
dead and I don't think they have any
plans to bring him back nor should they
um let's see ah who was your favorite
color book writer um probably jonathan
hickman he's really really good unless
you're talking about DC then it's jeff
jones Geoff Johns is hands down probably
the item well I'd say it's a toss-up
Scott Snyder is doing really good with
Batman but Geoff Johns did really good
with the flash Justice League and Green
Lantern and so on so he's a solid writer
let's see do you like the flash TV show
yes the flash TV show is really good
what do you think of Constantine joining
arrow I think that's a cool idea I think
the idea of Constantine being part of
arrow will provide a cool idea and
that's what they should have done to be
honest I don't think Constantine was
relevant enough that they gave him a
full TV show that was weird I mean it's
the reason why I got canceled but I
think he's interesting enough of a
character they could feature him in
other shows so do you think spider-man
should be in the MCU yeah Oh spider
woman should be in the MCU I don't care
enough about Spider Woman I don't think
anybody does to be honest I mean maybe a
handful of people but um um blow some
rings I'm not again I can't do vape
rings I wish I could but I can't have
you thought about producing your own
beats for your videos now I don't really
want to get in music production let's
see will you make a mutant x video I
don't think now there's not really
reason to unless they bring it back jim
Starlin is solid Jim Stalin is a really
good writer like his video or is a book
the Thanos revelation was actually like
an original graphic novel and it was
pretty awesome so it's pretty cool what
happens after infinity war in the comics
the Infinity quests it's weird who is
Constantine um el Constantine's a guy
that basically like chases demons you
know do you suck dick no but I do ban
which is what you're getting you're
getting a band forever although why that
have such a bone had a question what an
idiot let's see is daredevil the best
kind of book live-action TV show yet
yeah probably um Martian Manhunter
versus the vision Martian Manhunter do
you think Superman is boring because
he's 20 p yeah I mean it's hard to make
it hard to make a video about a
character um that is it's hard to make a
video about a character like that I mean
how do you make one intriguing like that
I mean it'sit's I don't know I mean it's
a guy that can do anything I mean why is
that relevant to me what happens after
infinity one of the movies we don't know
I have no idea I mean that movie hasn't
come out yet so secret bands oh yeah
yeah I mean I've an Iban with extreme
prejudice I mean if you don't want to
get banned all you have to do which is
not being an idiot it's not like it's
rocket science but that always cracks me
up people are like hey everybody look
how funny i am and it's like it's like
they walk into a room and say they crack
a joke that no one laughs it to me
that's what internet trolls are like
they're people that make jokes that
nobody laughs I and it's like I'm funny
I mean I know I'm the only one laughing
at my joke but I'm funny no now if you
were funny you wouldn't have to laugh at
your own joke see best jeph loeb comic
dare double yellow definitely
do you you change your setup nah me how
to switch everything around like moves
everything around I did that a while ago
why don't you use to which by the way I
preferred a live stream my Q&A on
youtube like i like that i like the idea
of a live stream my Q&A on youtube do
you think Batman vs Superman will suck
to a god no that's going to be good
Ronda Rousey waiting to play miss marvel
yes like I'm so down for seeing her play
miss marvel she looks like she could be
an authoritative one on that an
authoritative woman like I'm down for
seeing that do you think Michael corbat
should show up in the MCU no because you
would need Galactus you need you need a
lot of stuff now it wouldn't happen
let's see love your work thank you my
messages aren't being shown I don't
think yeah they are how would the Second
Amendment apply to Wolverine school uh I
mean the second woman has to do with
guns so I guess bear arms comedy is
subjective though but I guess it is but
I would say that if you're trying to be
funny I know what he's laughing but you
then you're probably not funny so um why
did you hate fan has look for so much it
wasn't that bad yes it was it was
definitely that bad um I love her but
she can't act she isn't she's been in
like one movie so um let's see do you
prefer comics too oh crap I missed that
um it's a body cleaner now this is water
this is Voss water not tricking shampoo
I'm not a crazy drug addict or anything
do you play Dungeons and Dragons no no I
don't um let's see what are your
favorite graphic novels top five thank
you graphic novels probably Jeff lobes
run of the Red Hulk I think spider-man
blue superman red Sun kingdom come and
probably probably the Infinity
revelation I want to be banned from not
being banned okay expendables 3 and fast
and furious she was in fast and furious
oh yeah she was a bodyguard yeah well
she never talked she dis acted yeah I
remember that um let's see who's the
next big bad guy in the MCU after Thanos
no clue I'm really actually curious to
see where they go I wish I wish I had an
idea like I mean there's so many people
they can do I have no earthly clue let's
see what are your hopes for Daredevils
season 2 that the punisher will play a
big role that's what I really want to
see I want to see the punisher is like
either like a main villain and like the
whole first half or something I'm really
curious why do they make Thor powers so
so low in the movies I don't understand
your question God King Robb I have a
question have you read any manga in your
life if so what's your favorite manga of
all time haven't really read me but I
love Dragon Balls a year so Adam warlock
would be a great character let's see
overrated comics anything Superman or
anything spider-man related let's see
Uncle Ben vs on May on they would went
out of that like she beat the crap out
of Uncle Ben plus she's been a Herald of
Galactus so top five crossovers yeah no
one would take some thinking playstation
or xbox and playstation i use i had xbox
for a long time I enjoy PlayStation
um explain static shock no no that's
probably not going to happen Dragon Ball
super videos now like I'm gonna do a top
five Tuesday top five like Dragon Ball Z
moments that's because I just feel like
it i talked about tuesday ages for me
which by the way i marvel request monday
is coming back and that's going to be
infinity war like i'm just going to give
you guys a whole infinity war story see
I told people my request monday was
coming back there were comics request
monday but nobody wanted to believe me I
was like it's coming back to her sick of
wars and they look nobody want to
believe me so um Silver Surfer vs. dr.
Manhattan dr. Manhattan did you like
spider verse now not really let's see
any chance oh crap are you friends with
comic story and yeah um let's see we're
did where to get more come from I
remember her origin story actually to be
honest what are you waited I i'm vaping
the exes this is the back of flavored
ejuice let's see what oh well somebody
asked that if door model would replace
Thanos in the MCU would that pose a
bigger threat that would be a good good
care to choose yes Dormammu is godly
powerful it's stupid how powerful he is
um yeah he would be be it'd be stupid to
have him in there be not not not stupid
bad he would be nuts because of how
strong he would be let's see have you
seen the Civil War teaser now oh he's a
month like a little 30-second thing with
crossbones you asking that let's see
have do you plan to explain the watchman
probably not what did you get your first
your first comic ooh I was like seven or
eight years old I think maybe a little
bit older than that my dad got me a copy
of the of a Batman comic and sovereign 7
let's see beta ray bill in the MCU that
I could see that happening that'd be a
cool movie like Thor for beta ray bill
like that the interesting um
let's see Rob do you watch rooster teeth
not really I man over they are but I
don't really watch them that much do you
like Star Wars yes I love Star Wars oh
yeah Kimura was raised by Thanos is
ready um let's see for your opinion on
my favorite villain Brainiac this woeful
intellect I mean he's a cool character
bridge semi reads back um she's usually
always busy during the weekly pool so
look how you guys make demands like do
this Rob it's like nope probably not no
like are you trying to get ignored
because that's how you get ignored what
were your thoughts on the recently
released Fantastic Four didn't like it
then like it at all um do you want
anything I'm making breakfast some eggs
bacon and my toast sounds good I need to
make some breakfast by the way let's see
fantastic for going back to MCU be nicer
they did it'd be a great announcement
Spidey as a netflix instead of movies
now spider-man's too big to put on
netflix they definitely need to keep him
in the films so let's see how do you
think the time Jim will be introduced
ooh let's see
I don't know I don't know some guy what
does some guideposts let's see your fat
and ugly kill your mom fatty Wow are you
mad because you can't make youtube
videos for a living because it sounds
like you're mad that you can't make
youtube videos for a living don't worry
like like start a YouTube channel and I
might I may give you a shout out but if
I find the time like I mean anybody else
I'd help out but you know I mean maybe I
could spare you a minute maybe I could
possibly help you out i don't know i
mean i don't know chances are though
that if you made a youtube channel it
would probably fail so no that wouldn't
waste my time see that's that's see that
that cracked me up man like like people
have posted the chat and then like
they'll try the like they'll troll your
you're a fat man with no life i'm a fat
man that gets paid to make youtube
videos like you're a kid that doesn't do
anything I'm just gonna ban that guy
like actually I'm gonna let him stay in
here like I'm gonna give that guy's life
meeting I'm gonna let him stay in here
I'm gonna let him continue serving some
purpose like oh yeah that dudes piss
like he's pissed like see that's this
that's the thing man like they don't
normally like I don't know I I guess you
don't really like you don't really get
like a grade on your unlike life like I
guess I don't really like a sonia like
an a it be a co d or f any or anything
like that but like if you're on the
internet trolling people then you
probably failed in your life guys never
going to amount to anything you are a
savage no way like do you think let's
see you are a beautiful man who has the
yeah I do like I have an amazing voice
it's not think people tell me that and
people are like man Rob you have an
amazing voice I'm like I hope I don't
know like I'm hopin going to sort of
YouTube channel on like doing audio
books like it's literally just like just
gonna be audio books that's all it's
going to be so
you are awesome raw love your stuff Rob
handles handles trolls like a champ oh
yeah like up let me tell you something
man like I'm not going to take seriously
some kid that's failed so completely in
their life that they're gonna get on
YouTube and try to give me a heart come
on get on my level bro like you got to
be where I'm at before you can give me a
hard time now if you had a channel with
a million subscribers then I'd say well
yeah you might be right but like not
only do you not have a youtube channel
you'll even have like you're now get out
of here when you take yourself seriously
I'll take you seriously so um let's see
do you see the MCU diving into more
galactic themed movies in fact I think
so like I really really think so because
here's here's a problem the the problem
that I have any way with the MCU so far
is that like the things are these are
slow like right now in count where I
guess in the movies because Rob's voice
Morgan Freeman's voice laughs I'm not
Morgan Freeman I'm not even close to
Morgan Freeman you're only 10 years old
well then you well then you've gotta
like one hell of a terrible life ahead
of you like you're going to have a
series of consistent failures in your
life that sucks for you anyway like I
think the problem with uh with the MCE
right now is as you have like with like
earthbound events and I mean there's a
great big huge expansive cosmos but
here's a problem they don't have
Galactus like they don't have a Silver
Surfer you know you got the guardians of
the galaxy but you know all the best
aspects of like the expansive Marvel
continuity outside the planet earth
involved like the lactis and they've all
I don't know it's gonna be tough to do I
mean it's gonna be hard to do I mean
that's why I'm in my personal opinion
like they jump the gun by introducing
Thanos this early I would have waited
like I would have waited until a few
more phases to introduce Thanos because
they know this is like a multi vert or i
guess a universal threat you know he's a
threat to everybody in the universe but
now it's just kind of like i don't know
if i consider okay fine you know here's
a question I have for you guys how many
of you guys are here
because of my voice like how many of you
guys enjoy the sound of my voice that's
what I want to know so yes yes fear The
Walking Dead comes on today yes I'm so
psyched I'm so psyched like I want to do
a video explaining like what happens to
the community and the walking dead
that's what I want to know what I go gay
for files hell yeah you were yeah I'd go
gay for no i'm not i'm not gonna go gay
but Faust is a you know he's a cool guy
here's a cool dad to talk to you so um
I'm not fat I'm big-boned no I'm fat
look I'm not I'm not confused um let's
see will they be brief spider-man will
they bring spidered win back oh I'm
pretty sure they will like my voice I
don't understand all of us it cracks me
up how many people are just like Rob
your voice is amazing I got a sweet
voice yeah I guess but you're also a big
fan of the comic content I mean I'm not
gonna be mad if you guys are just like
your video suck but your voice is
amazing like I'm not gonna be like well
then screw you i'm laying this whatever
i'm just curious yeah um let's see what
are you sipping in oh I mean it's is
coffee that I'm drinking so ah I don't
have the thing open up your clear voice
and you like comics um let's see Rob's
voice helps retain the information I
guess so your voice is amazing you
should do trailers you know periods do
I'd love to work with PewDiePie one day
even if he just doesn't give me a shout
out like I'd love to just work one day
with him I think it'd be cool um your
opinion on mr. Sunday movies he's
hilariously I love his videos what audio
books like I'm think about doing like
Alice in Wonderland but I'm thinking
about starting with like like like
nonfiction you know like biographies
stuff like that like 12 years a slave or
so if Morgan Freeman head about or fig I
do a biography about Morgan Freeman
and like I think I'd be cool way like
read Morgan Freeman's biography on
youtube like that video would blow up it
would be so cool where's the monster
drink I already have I'm also drink this
one favorite book harry potter the harry
potter series definitely my favorite
books let's see really you're drinking
coffee i'll finally we drink a coffee
Rob's voice explained ah in a World in a
world and I mean like okay so so like
like my voice can go my voice can
actually get pretty deep well not not
that deep but would like deep enough
like i mean i like i like the radio say
like you're listening to k doz Cato's
your number one source for jazz music
like i like i like like the radio effect
of talking but unless you know it's just
kind of fun but if you guys love my
voice cool beans so any chance that dr.
doom well um let's see PewDiePie
explained do you find it hard to find
people with the next okay these
questions are rolling in so fast now
dammit um well see how do you feel about
spider-man in the MCU I'm really psyched
about it do you listen to smodcast no
let's see do you know who Scott Pilgrim
is so I've never heard the stories
mother explains how do you make a good
Fantastic Four movie I did it was called
give me the rights back to marvel's
house of him thoughts it was already
deep enough for oh I'm not saying that
the man with the golden voice I don't
know about that I imagine that though
like I imagine like started because this
oh okay I'll be honest with you guys you
know with this with this whole thing
i'll be i'll be honest i would love to
start an audiobook channel and it's just
reading like because i got three books
in the public domain I couldn't read
books that are licensed and owned by a
company because then I wanted a
copyright problems and so like classic
works are usually what's in the public
domain like like Frankenstein alison
wonderland
Moby Dick stuff like that like the cloud
no literary classics basically books
around before copyright laws kicked in
and I imagine like starting a YouTube
channel based on that reading those
audiobooks and then it just like blows
up but millions of subscribers you know
and tie magazines like he's the man with
the golden voice that he's the next
Morgan Freeman you know it'd be it'd be
funny I don't think it ever get to that
point but I think it'd be I think it'd
be funny are you single yes yes I am I
had a girlfriend for a little while
didn't quite work out and yeah I ended
up like whoa we broke up but I ended it
um let's see how do you think spooderman
will come into the Civil War I think
he's going to come in with with oh I
don't know that's gonna be interesting I
don't think they're doing origin stories
anymore so I'm not sure it's a good
question I think it'll just be like
Peter Parker to be honest like I think
they'll just talk about Peter Parker I
don't think you'll be spider-man during
civil war buddy might be so I don't know
what's your favorite new 52 story arc
probably Superman truth right now I mean
I know it's considered ECU but it's I
consider a new 42 because it takes place
in the new 52 you know continuity so
let's see no but it's good to dream yeah
it's good to dream um you should read
The Wizard of Oz follow your dreams
let's see you're here for the voice you
think you're being ignored you're not
being a going um DC universe is going to
be better than the MCU no I don't think
so do you hate the Inhumans as much as
sound no I think the Inhumans are cool
you're single because you're oh my god
man this kid dude like this kid this
gets cracking me up man damn dude I mean
I don't mind like like everybody needs
something to laugh at it right now I was
laughing it back man um let's see why do
they keep rebooting movies I don't know
okay it's time to come up with some
original ideas is what it's time to do
and like they just don't they just don't
do that and it kind of sucks you know
but don't let your dude don't let your
dreams be dreams it just steward play
the guitar for us now
okay you know like this is that knee
okay i'll talk about knee okay thank you
show me okay look like obviously you
want me to help you become successful on
YouTube so send me an email and you
don't stand a chance like Robert you
don't stand a chance calm like send me
an email of that email address and like
I will help you start a YouTube channel
that you will inevitably fail at and
like definitely all right um hey you're
a big fan awesome ah let's see Rob core
explained I don't know it's the name of
you guys so like well you guys are the
Watchers but somehow people come up with
a rob course so are we gonna change it
like from The Watcher so no I'm not
gonna block that guy located look
everybody needs something to laugh at
and right now I'm laughing at that guy
so like um let's see Cain the Conqueror
and the MCU uh can you date me know do
you know what fantastic what fantastic
beasts and where to find them is if not
all of you I can't wait to read that
like I'm really actually interested in
reading that they get hard for the
ladies let's see trolling the troll like
a boss oh yeah like I think he's trying
like I'm I think I say that's a problem
like I think he's trying to troll like
if he's trying to troll he's doing a bad
job it was like the purpose of trolling
is to get somebody angry like to get
them irritated and it get upset at you
but like he's doing a terrible job he
doesn't know how to troll like how do
you not know how to troll like come on
kid like you can't like trolling is
making somebody mad you can't even do
that right like you're never gonna be
able to do anything right in your life I
mean am Kid come on let's see do you
like east of west I haven't read it yet
like I don't know what that is to be
honest I don't schematically I know it's
a bang but I haven't haven't really read
it um let's see do you think they won't
fully portray the hoax full power in the
movies well see that's kind of the
kicker's they haven't really had a
reason to like the Hulk hasn't gone
against somebody who's so strong that
he's had to like but he just reaches the
point where he just loses all
sanity and just snaps like they haven't
had that yet I think that it will
probably have that an infinity war where
we'll see like like world war hulk level
Incredible Hulk but I'm until now he's
never been you know never had a reason
to get that mad so um let's see fast
versus Tiffani I think Tiffany would win
that fight Tiffany like I let me know is
I met in hung out on Tiffany in New York
and she seems like somebody yeah that
guy needs trolling excellent like I'm
gonna make a video called trolling
explain for that guy so he actually
knows what it is cuz I don't think he
knows what it is like um if you want to
troll Rob asking that invincible let's
see ok what is what is this trolling
saying I can't read a thing that you had
a suit yeah the chat is really fast like
I tried to kiss thing as often as I can
but um let's see what are your thoughts
on the train is too let's see the
purpose of trolling is to get attention
and he's doing that I guess I mean I
don't know hey look if it gives that
kid's life purpose to to get some
attention in a chat then I mean I don't
mind helping him out like i don't mind
giving him a reason to live a me for all
I know this kid could be on the fence
you know ready to slit his wrists and if
I can keep him from you know doing the
world like if I can do the world a
disservice by keeping that kid alive
well then I guess you know that's that's
kind of a good thing um let's see okay
now we starting to get annoying like
we'll just lock that kid all right kid
if you if you are having like dangerous
thoughts and you're considering like
hurting yourself then please go through
with it please do it like please hurt
yourself kid like I promise you like no
one will care oh my god where's this
kids coming at like I'm trying to find
that kid seemed very white now I'm not
gonna say Barry White yeah it'd be fun
to seem very white but um I'd love to
sing very white but i'm not i'm not that
good like there we go there it is all
right
uh block okay that kids block forever
all right um Rob you're one of all of
YouTube channels now not by launching
can you have his boots Seattle oh haha
um I know you just entered that kids
live you just enter the kid's life
hopefully I don't care about that kid
and the kid sucks you know if trolling
on the internet was the only thing
keeping that kid from losing his mind
than the night kid this needs to go away
let's see he needs the time runs out
yeah yeah yeah good luck trolling me a
my own chat like I think that kid failed
to understand that he's he you have no
power here rest in peace kid now just
yeah just be gone um let's see what do
you what do you think about George
Miller doing man of steel to you i'm
actually not upset about it like like
I'm actually pretty psyched about it
like I think that's gonna be pretty
awesome um the comics and coffee is
slowly turning into Robbie spawned of
trolls it gets worse you sweet this
ignore me I mean it's funny to me like I
mean yeah I guess the response its rules
if you ignore the fact that like I'm
answering a ton of questions and yeah
sure it's turning and I just responded
trolls the you stream on Twitch the
weekly pull streams on twitch you have
very nice living quarters thank you you
have a very nice about mesial it's
that's a funny way to let's see natural
was probably 30 years old yeah probably
I mean he's going nowhere in life doing
nothing living in his mom's basement I
don't know who cares nobody cares about
that kid um let's see how do you Robbie
you think Thanos will be defeated ooh
how do i think thatís will be defeated
as somebody will probably steal the end
still the Infinity gem from them or
still the Infinity Gauntlet it makes the
most sense do you like waffles yeah what
the hell doesn't like waffles if you
don't like waffles smack yourself
because waffles are amazing
I still think you're awesome well I
appreciate it meet agreed add new york
comic con and that'd be cool I think
we're planning something like that like
why are trolls here anyway because
they're jealous that they can't be me I
kind of think I think they should kind
of all they should have kept man of
steel as it was it was perfect man o
steel was fine it wasn't bad at all you
have a nice hairline it's kind of
crooked but whatever there's more
important things in the world that I
care about then you know then then like
my hairline so let's see well will you
ever do video games explain nah probably
not Marvel needs to stop trolling it's
bill and stop killing us villains no way
you know some of the villains need to go
but a lot of them you to say I agree you
know um can you explain the sinestro
corps war we'll see what's up I mean the
Sinestro Corps is really important right
now so there's some there's some super
important things going on um let's see
made my day answered two of your watch
it slow I'm glad I'm glad you and let it
happen to get done what are your
thoughts on Batman hush I wasn't the
biggest fan of hush I thought it was an
interesting story but it wasn't enough
for me to be compelled about it I mean s
well the reason why I just never did a
video on it like I know Benny was really
huge on hush and this channel i think
has a lot more DC fans and i am but
that's what I'm doing DC videos I'm
trying to break into that DC market but
yeah like it's not the biggest fan of
hush living in your parents basement law
well it's actually cuz I'm disabled and
unable to work I pay rent though well
that's that's cool i mean if you're
disabled we can't work it's all good no
um let's see what do I think about you
vons was for Captain Marvel I'm now with
that whoever that is trolling villain
with controlling villains works well too
yeah that'd be kind of funny just like
troll let's roll dr. doom let's see
good day Rob do you think secret war
story will ever get indian now I don't
think so what are you most excited for
when the taken King expansion the new
rain and the fact that you know I saw
why furs are getting a getting a buff um
do you think Hawkeye should be in uh oh
so good well crap i lost that question
how do i think about injustice i haven't
read it yet i love how they showed the
sewer and the daredevil series when the
chemicals yeah the connection with the
days with Ninja Turtles do you wish
there was more mature mature way I mean
you got the DC max lineup yeah that's
adult oriented so i guess i'm sorry the
marble max line up whether that's the
door lanten let's see what do you most
already after that what do you think
about the death of superman lives oh you
mean we born a Kentucky no i was born in
memphis tennessee do you think Hawkeye
would be cooler and get more attention
on how guy is an interesting character
but he's not really been relevant he's
never really hat while ye he's only had
his own series recently that's because
of the movies up until then he never had
his own series he was always a
background character so i don't know i
mean he's sorry um let's see touba
swagged some of the comments you guys
make her a little funny to me should all
may have died assume you're talking
about during out one more day what do
you think about Black Bolt black balls a
cool character it's kind of weird like
he's an interesting character um I'm
curious to see how they're going to
betray him in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe let's see are you excited for
castings and Luke Cage yes I'm really
excited for Luke Cage Rob whoo what you
doing explaining about the Superman
truth arcane HIV yeah when it finishes
um let's see Doctor Doom vs spawn
dr. him probably he's been to hell and
back so like literally Rob do you think
Deadpool will catch out catches family a
Stanley cameo he may or may not unless
you're Stanley's always appeared in
movies for characters that he's created
so I don't know I mean he created the
Avengers like they created most of the
characters in The Avengers Stanley
didn't create Deadpool so I know I mean
maybe though it'd be cool if he was
let's see hey Rob do you think Deadpool
will okay already answer that um what do
you think about comic-con I love the
character of comic-con I think she's a
great character Star Wars or Star Trek
fan I'm actually both like I like both
of them I know it's blasphemy i know you
has to be one of the other you can't
like both but i like both can you
explain the post-credit scene and
ant-man what was the post-credit scene
in name oh that's for a captain america
the winter soldier reverso or rather go
to the got to go to the gym oh yeah go
to the gym if you need to go you know
don't blow off staying in shape because
of my livestream I mean this thing
probably going to you know probably
gonna bounce here in the next couple
minutes anyway um Batman kills the
marvel universe I would read the hell
out of that Batman kills the marvel
universe would be amazing I Rob are you
mixed black and white yes do I think
Wonder Woman gal Godot is too skinny yes
like she's a very skinny Wonder Woman
like we need like a wonder woman that's
that's like you know like not not
necessarily like plus-sized but we need
a Wonder Woman it looks like she could
hold her own like gal Godot looks like
you could pick her up and throw her into
a wall like a stiff breeze would lower
right over like that's that's going to
be the source of contention like wait
like wait until that movie comes out and
there's going to be a big discussion
over the depiction of Wonder Woman in
that movie unless you just put on some
weight which I down Rob you made my day
thank you for your response subscriber
for life right here well that's awesome
thank you how is the Jeff Jones Justice
League run it's amazing like it's really
really good let me see Rob could you
please make a video on common sense and
explain why it makes for a little sick
um let's see Barry Allen or Wally West
Barry Allen um let's say yeah thick
there we go that's a good phrase ah
voluptuous I don't want to use afraid of
a lump service because it might sound I
might sound like like you know like
creepy you know like we needed a
voluptuous one wonder when Weeden one is
like curves and it sound that's that was
something really creepy let's see we
need a way to crossfit wonder woman
Serena Williams's Wonder Woman Every
interesting see Rob kills his whole
universe all right guys we're going to
bring this to an end um we're just going
to go we're going to go ahead and bounce
off here um but yeah thanks for coming
out today guys I will see you guys next
week on next sunday for college the
coffee and on Tuesday for the weekly
pool which should be on Twitch unless we
decide to cancel it which I don't think
we will but uh yes so um I will catch
you guys later peace